and I know so you were 28 at the time so
you weren't really or maybe 10 years
older
sounds like than a lot of people John
might have been 28 or thereabout I was
25 I mean there's a few year age
difference we were both in our mid 20s
with the late 20s what have you around
then you know we were you know yeah we
clearly we weren't that much older but
maybe 10 years or less less than 10
years or in some cases I mean there
might have been people our age there I'm
sure there were absolutely we could have
been there it just wasn't the music that
we were really into but we were mean I
tell you I'm very fortunate that that it
was Judas Priest because their music
still you know they're still viable
vital and their music holds up I mean
the anthems are still you know classic
heavy metal anthems you know the our
other artists that the people are
talking about or Metallica still you
know very much a current band and
Madonna
you know mentioning Madonna all of that
I think has helped with the shelf-life
because there's so many other bands and
or you know topics of discussion that
could have prevailed and not really lent
itself to this nearly three decade
conversation about this 16 minute video
and what is your take on the whole sort
of whatever you couldn't want to call it
the headbanger heavy metal you know hair
metal culture you know you had the the
hippies before them there was punk rock
you know now you have sort of emo goth
but what was the prevailing you know
what were wild young and free kind of
thing oh I don't know I mean I think
again I always said that yeah I mean for
this for heavy metal parking lot I've
always said you were either at that
concert or you sat next to someone in
homeroom at that concert you know you it
was just you didn't have to be a heavy
metal fan to really understand or
appreciate what was going on and I I
think at the time that music was very
a pop but just the kind of fan I mean
that's it's really just about the fans
and fan you know fan fan demand and and
and you know just being a music fan and
because I think you could replace the
heavy metal with you know a country or
some other you know you to or whoever
with something though the love fish you
know you could really find these
passionate fans and just about any
parking lot but the hair metal and the
heavy metal and the attire and the you
know alcohol consumption might have been
it all added it really kept it ratcheted
it up for for us with heavy metal
parking lot and it just all was a
perfect storm I guess of all these
different elements that have kept it
still a title that I'm both John and I
are very grateful to still be talking
about almost thirty years later
you